with the release of far cry 6 we decided
to go back to the very beginning to see
just how far the franchise has come from
impressive tech demo to goofy open world
juggernaut
for more deep dives into your favorite
game series make sure to like this video
and subscribe to the channel
[Music]
it started in 1999. developers from
german studio crytek had one hell of a
time getting to e3 that year they almost
missed their flight didn't have a hotel
and had to shell out the last of their
money to pay for passes eventually they
made it into e3 and were permitted 15
minutes to show their work at the nvidia
booth back then crytek had a demo for
something made in their cryengine called
exile dinosaur island in which players
walk around an island populated with
dinosaurs
the cryengine boasted some of the most
impressive graphics at the time water
had reflections the lush island was huge
and the draw distance was unlike
anything anyone had ever seen
nvidia snapped up exile to be a
benchmarking software to ship with their
new graphics cards and ubisoft signed it
to become a full aaa game
in 2004 exile launched as a pc game
called far cry there's a lot of modern
far cry dna present even at the very
beginning open sandbox environments
vehicles the ability to approach
encounters in multiple ways an
underwhelming multiplayer and so on
however the first game goes off in a
sci-fi direction that the franchise
never really revisited you play as jack
carver ex-us army special forces who
finds himself washed up on a mysterious
tropical island after the boat he was
charting is attacked by mercenaries he
scours the island searching for the
woman who he was transporting killing
mercenaries along the way seems pretty
straightforward but before long you
start running up against
trigens the hell is that thing it must
be a tragen see the mercenaries were
hired by a man named dr krieger to
protect his pet project genetically
enhanced soldiers traversing the lush
jungle was made all the tougher by
mercenaries using the dense foliage for
cover as they'd sometimes opt to sneak
up on you rather than coming at you guns
blazing the island was a standout
location and there was an immense
juxtaposition between the cheery
colourful backdrop and the lingering
creepiness from what was happening there
upon release far cry was a critical and
commercial success with most of the
praise going to its visuals gamespot
viewer jason ocampo called it the best
single-player first-person shooter since
half-life and couldn't stop gushing
about how it looked far cry is a
stunning game in so many ways it
certainly raises the bar for graphics to
new heights and yet it's not just a
technology demonstration others felt
similarly and the game sold over 730 000
copies in four months with ubisoft fast
tracking a console release far cry had
put crytek a previously unknown
developer on the map and in 2004 the
studio signed a deal with ea to leave
far cry behind and create a new game
franchise for pc crisis
ubisoft montreal took over development
of the console version of far cry and it
launched for the original xbox in late
2005. due to processing limitations on
the xbox the game needed to be rebuilt
from the ground up to get it to run on
the console and the graphics while still
incredibly impressive for the og xbox
weren't quite as good to offer something
new to returning players a number of
gameplay features were added including
more vehicles dual wielding and the
ability to set traps that you could lure
your enemies into
not only that but you yourself became a
weapon you were injected with an
experimental serum and gained feral
abilities such as superhuman strength
speed and the power to see the scent
trails of your enemies which proved
incredibly useful in the dense jungle it
really captured the feeling that you
were evolving and changing over time and
that was reflected in the gameplay
although the players started outnumbered
and outgunned they'd eventually overcome
whether with firepower or abilities
multiplayer also received some tweaks it
wasn't exactly the most notable part of
the pc version but on xbox it received
some new modes and a level editor with
the ability to share maps via xbox live
far cry instincts was also released in
arcade as a two-person rail shooter in
2007 under the name paradise lost and it
wasn't long before the remake slash port
got its own sequel expansion far cry
instinct's evolution launched on the
original xbox in march 2006 and picked
up the story where instincts left off
following the beleaguered jack carver
who was still stuck in paradise on the
run from rebels and of course animal
human hybrids the story was about half
the length of instincts but the levels
were a bit more open-ended there were
new vehicles multiplayer received new
maps and modes and you had a bigger
arsenal including molotov cocktails it
didn't exactly reinvent the wheel but if
you were hankering for more far cry at
the time this was a nice little extra
instincts wasn't backwards compatible on
the xbox 360 though so if you had one of
microsoft's shiny new consoles and
wanted to play you had to grab far cry
instincts predator look i didn't name
these predator packaged instincts and
evolution together for the new console
but it received some flack because the
graphics weren't quite up to par with
other 360 games at the time
the same week ubisoft launched evolution
and predator it announced that it had
secured all rights to the far cry series
bagging both the intellectual property
and quote a perpetual license to use the
cry engine far cry edition
that engine would eventually be tweaked
and adapted by ubisoft into its own
engine dunya far cry made its way onto
the nintendo wii in late 2006 and it was
a bit of a mess ubisoft had taken parts
of some levels from the xbox version of
the game and mashed them up with new
content specifically for the wii like
the training level and levels that just
basically became shooting galleries
the ai wasn't the cleverest and had
pretty bad aim making the game a breeze
it had a split screen multiplayer but it
was limited to only two players which
didn't really make for the most
thrilling deathmatch mode story-wise it
threw you in at the deep end offering no
exposition as to who jack carver was or
why he had weird superhuman abilities
and for a game series known for its
outstanding visuals the wii just
couldn't compete but far cry vengeance
wouldn't be the lowest low for the
franchise
oh no
far cry
a history of far cry wouldn't be a
history of far cry without mention of
the awful movie that was released in
2008 directed by oui bol yes that one
who apparently snapped up the rights
before the game even launched it follows
jack carver roughly through the plot of
the first game and it's frankly speaking
pretty awful i won't subject you to too
much of it shocking no one it completely
bombed
let him loose let's see how he moves no
i cannot do that without sedating him
he would kill everybody in this room
including me although one fun fact about
it is that on the dvd there's a
commentary track with ball some
producers
and
the intern
weird shortly after the movie came out
so did the game's sequel
far cry 2.
it took players to 50 square kilometers
of african wilderness and at the time
ubisoft really really wanted you to know
how big that map was
far cry 2 was an ambitious mix of
open-ended game design multiple
interacting gameplay systems and a
bigger emphasis on realism yes of course
fire propagation and malaria too you
were a mercenary sent to an unnamed
african nation at the height of a civil
war to take out an arms dealer known as
the jackal and far cry 2 offered you a
lot of freedom in how you chose to play
to achieve this objective your map would
display available missions each with
different rewards and depending on what
you were after you could undertake them
in whichever order you liked and in more
creative ways the day night cycle
impacted enemy behavior so you could put
off finding a target until night time
where you'd be less visible or you could
let the environment do the work for you
the weather conditions changed the
battlefield in interesting ways fog
could hide your position and wind could
turn a small fire into a blazing inferno
you had buddies dotted around the map
which would act as the forebearers of
the guns for higher mechanic in later
far cry games who appeared in your game
was randomized but by undertaking
missions with them you'd increase your
relationship
they could also die
not all of far cry 2's mechanics were
beloved though the game had a weapon
degradation mechanic and not only that
your character also kind of had malaria
this meant that every so often your
character would need to take pills to
stay alive farcry 2 was ambitious and it
suffered from numerous technical issues
at launch but overall it was widely
praised and it's amazing to look back
and see just how much other far cry
games have borrowed from it
pre-production on far cry 3 started in
2008 and originally attempted to bring
together the previous games into one
cohesive narrative but after some key
staff from the previous games left
ubisoft plans for far cry 3 shifted
according to ex-narrative designer
rafael van lierop the game became a
little more mainstream it returned to
the jungle ditching the gritty aesthetic
of far cry 2 for a sunnier more colorful
approach it did however continue with
its fish out of water shtick the game
follows protagonist jason brody who
visits the lush rook islands with his
friends on a holiday of a lifetime but
they're all captured by pirate leader
vas montenegro jason manages to escape
and finds himself working with the
island's residents to try and rescue his
friends and get rid of the pirates
terrorizing the island continuing the
tradition of the villain being far more
interesting than the protagonist the
character that caught everyone's
attention was pirate lord vas portrayed
by michael mando i don't have to tell
you about the infamous definition of
insanity speech but it immediately
became iconic and even won a golden
joystick award for best gaming moment
it's like water under the bridge
did i ever tell you the definition
of insanity
mando also played the character in the
game's spin-off live action series the
far cry experience which also featured
christopher mintz place aka
mclovin
i am mclovin
rook islands was an expansive sandbox
filled with things to do and everything
offered players progression there was
crafting skill points and in what would
become classic ubisoft fair there were
outposts to liberate and watch towers to
climb you weren't just up against the
pirates who had taken over the island
there were also animals to hunt and by
collecting their pelts you could upgrade
your equipment far cry 3 also features
one of the series most iconic missions
burning marijuana fields to make it
bundem by skrillex and damian marley
the story caught some black particularly
in its portrayal of the island's native
inhabitants but when it came to critical
and commercial reception rook islands
and vass were the stars far cry 3 was
praised for its open world the
interacting systems and vassa's
charismatic presidents
within two years it had sold 10 million
copies and firmly cemented far cry as
one of ubisoft's blockbuster franchises
on april fool's day 2013 ubisoft
released a teaser trailer and a website
for a project called far cry 3 blood
dragon given its over-the-top neon 80s
aesthetic it was assumed by many to be
an april fool's day prank but no it was
an actual standalone game that was
released a month later it gently took
the piss and revered the action movies
and saturday morning cartoons of the
1980s in equal measure and featured a
soundtrack by synthwave duo powerglove
that absolutely banged
it plays almost identically to far cry 3
but you take on the role of cybernetic
super soldier sergeant rex power cult
voiced by terminator and alien star
michael bean it was a hit both
commercially and critically and in 2021
adi shankar executive producer of the
netflix castlevania series announced an
animated series set in blood dragon's
world called captain laser hawk a blood
dragon remix a remastered version of the
game would also be bundled with far cry
6. after the enormous success of far cry
3 ubisoft immediately began working on a
sequel early on in development the team
talked about making it a direct one that
continued jason's journey on rook
islands they even discussed bringing
back everyone's favorite baddie vas
according to producer dan hay those
talks lasted for about four days before
the team decided to up sticks from rook
island
and set the game in the fictional
country of kirat in the himalayas
i've cleared my calendar for you
you
and i
are gonna test [ __ ] up
playing is rj gale a young kirati
american who continues the fish out of
water trend by returning to his native
country to spread his mother's ashes but
finds kirat in the middle of a civil war
between a rebel movement called the
golden path and the royal army which is
led by its eccentric king pagan min who
was voiced by troy baker
far cry 4 added choices to gameplay with
you choosing ultimately who would rule
kirat gameplay-wise it also expanded on
what people loved most about far cry 3
its world adding more activities
customization and quests wildlife wasn't
just something to hunt or be hunted by
now you could ride an elephant into
battle like a tank or issue orders to a
tiger during the trippy shangri-la
missions
or if you fancied getting some more air
a gyrocopter was available to ride and
leap into battle from a mechanic cut
from far cry 3 made it into four guns
for hire which allowed your buddy to
play the game cooperatively with you and
if played on a playstation console the
keys to kirat offer meant that you could
play with a friend who didn't even own
the game for up to two hours far cry 4
was the biggest launch for the franchise
so far with ubisoft announcing that it
sold 7 million copies in its first few
months on sale
in 2016 another spin-off was released
and while it kept the spirit of far cry
it was a real departure for starters it
wasn't set in the modern age at all
instead going all the way back to 10 000
bc
as takara a member of the wenger tribe
you find yourself in a harsh foreign
valley and must build up your village
while fighting off rival tribes and
predators
naturally there are no guns to be had
and so clubs bows slings and eventually
bombs helped you cut through your
enemies
while far cry had dabbled with bringing
animals into the gameplay mix far cry
primal committed takart was able to talk
to animals and bring them on side and
like controlling the tiger in far cry 4
you were able to sick your furry friends
onto your enemies
instead of having a camera or binoculars
to tag enemies in the distance you had a
pet owl to do that for you one of the
coolest things about primal was that
ubisoft worked with language experts to
create a language just for the game with
distinct dialects for the different
tribes
for palsy khan
who have patash
far cry primal definitely lent more into
the prey becomes predator elements of
far cry but those who miss the bombastic
nature of the franchise didn't have that
long to wait
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
far cry 5 returned players to modern ish
civilization specifically hope county
montana which was home to doomsday cult
called the project at eden's gate
instead of just one antagonist though
you were up against a whole family
although the cult was headed up by the
charismatic and dangerous joseph seed
players had to first get through the
lieutenants before taking a shot at the
leader far cry 5 was certainly the most
open of any of the titles as soon as you
got through the tutorial you were
dropped into hope county and were able
to tackle it in any order you liked
skills weren't locked by prerequisite
skills meaning you could hone your
playstyle quickly by undertaking
activities in its three regions you
would earn resistance points make enough
of a nuisance of yourself and you'd
catch the attention of the ruling
lieutenant who you'd then have to face
far cry 5 took away ubisoft's beloved
watchtowers and mini-maps to encourage
exploration and interaction with the
world far cry 5 also doubled down on ai
helping you out guns for hire brought
specialist characters along for the ride
with you thanks for hire meanwhile
allowed the player to recruit animals
like cheeseburger the bear or boom of
the dog to help you out or you could
bring your real life friends along for
the ride
far cry arcade let you make your own
maps using assets from far cry 5 other
far cry games and even other ubisoft
games like assassin's creed and
watchdogs gameplay-wise far cry 5
certainly seemed to be trying new things
and getting a lot of it right
the story however was pretty polarizing
due to its themes of separatism
religious fanaticism and similarities
with far-right political movements that
seem to mirror events in the real world
it didn't help that ubisoft actively
shied away from making any kind of
definitive political statement while
evoking the hot button issues of the
times it was released in
the game was the fastest selling in the
franchise and in may 2019 ubisoft
revealed that in under a year it had
become the best selling ubisoft game of
the entire console generation it
eventually received a bunch of wacky dlc
featuring some of the supporting
characters from the game
spoilers for the good ending of far cry
5 here but at the end of that game
joseph seed
detonates a nuke
new dawn takes place 17 years later in
hope county albeit on a smaller version
of the map in the game a bunch of
survivors struggle to rebuild while
facing off against the highway men who
were scavengers attempting to take
everything that's left after the nuke a
superbloom re-vegetated the land
replacing the brown palette we've come
to associate with post-apocalyptic games
with dashes of pinks and greens
gameplay wise new dawn introduced damage
numbers and tiered enemies effectively
gating your progress and preventing you
from easily journeying around hope
county
it also gave you superpowers kind of
reminiscent of far cry instincts reviews
were mixed and its sales reflected this
ubisoft is really having a moment where
it's trying to pull on nostalgia strings
in an attempt to generate goodwill
can't think why but anyway far cry vr
dive into insanity is in development and
it's a virtual reality experience that
will take players back to rook islands
and yes you guessed it reunite you with
vas
but that's not the only place he's gonna
be cropping up he'll play a role in the
upcoming far cry 6 dlc we'll get to that
in a sec but the latest iteration of the
series is gonna take us to the fictional
caribbean island of yara inspired by war
torn cuba
you'll play as danny rojas nope not that
one a different one that's part of the
local guerrilla resistance who are
trying to remove corrupt dictator anton
castillo from his rule still though
football is life castillo is played by
giancarlo esposito who you may know from
his iconic role in breaking bad castillo
rules with an iron fist and is training
up his young son diego to take his place
far cry 6 is said to be the biggest game
to date and it brings back a lot of what
we know and love like cute animals
playing alongside you this here for
example is chorizo the dog
good dog
good dog
you'll also be able to play the whole
game in co-op leaning into the gorilla
resistance themes resolver weapons are
unique weapons that are improvised from
junk like the saw blade that plays the
macarena the supremo backpacks act as
more heavy hitting pieces of equipment
and can be used as jet packs
flamethrowers or projectile launchers
if far cry 5 shied away from making a
political message far cry 6's developers
have actively said it'll be a political
game while the cuban revolution acted as
inspiration the game's political
messages will be firmly within the
context of the fictional country of yara
the far cry 6 season pass includes new
story episodes where you can play as
some of far cry's most infamous villains
vas pagan min and joseph seed there'll
also be dlc missions featuring danny
trejo and crossovers with rambo and
stranger things
so there we have it the history of far
cry from its humble beginnings to
present day for more on the game
subscribe or head over to gamespot.com
where you can also learn more about
ubisoft's employees taking action to
change hostile company culture and how
the company itself has responded thanks
for watching i'm on twitter at lucy
james games and we'll see you next time
[Music]
you